hi I'm Linda 80 with 23andme and I have
some information to share here on
YouTube which is great we're here at the
World Economic Forum and one of the
challenges we face within 23 and me and
also as a global problem is the
patenting of the human genome and we're
really interested in hearing back from
the community about thoughts on how we
can get around this problem of creating
almost like a quilt or a patchwork of
ownership of new genome by companies
invite institutions universities we just
think this is untenable for the future
especially when we get to a point where
we can sequence the entire genome how on
earth is someone going to get access to
all of their information if if it's all
of a patchwork and and people think they
claim ownership of the genome so we
would like to pose this question and our
position is that we don't think that
this is right that some company or
institution can own a piece of your
genome it's okay for them to make a drug
against a piece of the genome or to
innovate on the genomes but simply by
being able to read it and tell you what
that information means we think is it's
just not the wave of the future and it's
really going to block innovation as
company so that's my challenge to all of
you Thanks